.
Mme Hivon, tout le monde ava mot
que de bons mots pour vous
aujourd'hui. D'ailleurs, vous
êtes une des rares qui fait
l'unanimité. Vous avez plutôt
des éloges, la plupart du temps.
Vous êtes béni, votre travail a
fait pour le droit à mourir dans
la dignité entre autres, qu'il
y a un gct qui s'est
installé?
- Écoutez, je ne sais pas.
C'est peut-être à des analystes
de le dire, je suis très
surprises de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui. C'est sur que je me
sens extrêmement reconnaissante,
d'avoir pu tisser tous ces liens
avec autant de gens qui nous ont
amené à co-construire des
réformes. Et puis c'est sûr
que quand j'ai fait le saut
en politique, je m'étais fait
une promesse: c'est qu'il y
avait tellement de gens
désabusés de la politique,
qui trouvait que c'était tous
du pareil au même que c'était
des fois un cycle le salon bleu.
Je voulais vraiment rebâti
de la confiance à l'égard de la
politique. Y compris, pas juste
sur les réformes de fond, mais
sur la manière dont on exerce
la politique. Alors c'est sûr
que de ce côté-là, de sentir
ces commentaires là à ce sujet-
là ça me fait chaud au coeur.
- Et là, pourquoi exactement,
vous vous sentez étouffé? Vous
sentez prisonnière de la ligne
de parti? Pourquoi à ce
moment-ci?
- Pourquoi, tout simplement,
parce qu'avant de renouveler
nos voeux en quelque sorte avec
l'engagement politique, je pense
qu'il faut vraiment aller voir
ce qu'il y a en nous. Moi quand
je me suis lancé en politique,
je pensais faire deux, tout au
plus trois mandats. J'en ai fait
quatre. En fait, j'ai vraiment,
pendant des mois, sonder mon âme
et mon coeur parce que j'adore
ce que je fais. J'ai encore
plein de combativité, j'ai aimé
chaque minute de la vie
politique. Mais je dois dire
qu'il y n-là qui
revenait toujours à la surface,
d'avoir un plus grand espace de
liberté. de normalité.
Parce qu'un moment donné, après
14 ans de vie politique, c'est
comme siaucoup
de figures imposées, beaucoup
d'instantanéité. Peu de temps
pour la réflexion.
ne de parti aussi.
- Ça c'est certain, mais je
pense qu'au-delà de ça il y a
comme une espèce de réalité qu'à
our on se lève, on lit
quatre ou cinq journaux, vous
savez ce que c'est. On doit
avoir des réactions sur tout ets
beaucoup de place à la nuance, à
prendre son temps. C'est tous
des choses avec lesquelles j'aie
goût de voir autre chose. J'ai
le goût de contribuer autrement,
en ayant un peu plus d'espace de
réflexion et pas juste comme je
l'ai dit, exister par et pour la
politique.
- Quand vous dîtes contribuer
autrement, est-ce que vous
renoncez à jamais une carrière
politique, où vous dîtes, on
verra?
- C'est une décision mûrement
réfléchie et c'est sûr que je
ferme clairement un chapitre.
Est-ce que je ferme le livre au
complet, pour toujours?
Aujourd'hui ce serait trop
difficile de vous dire ça. Il y
a quand même un petit deuil et
une désintoxication que je vais
devoir faire. Mais c'est certain
que je veux me réaliser. Je veux
accomplir des choses avec les
Québécois autrement.
- Dans votre prise de décision,
est-ce que vous êtes dit, c'est
sûr que ça va être interprété
comme étant, je quitte parce que
le PQ est en train de mourir.
Est-ce que vous êtes même dit je
ne peux pas m'en aller ça va
avoir l'air épouvantable, je
suis l'un de ses piliers du
parti?
- Je ne suis pas folle, je suis
la politique, je savais que ce
serait un élément qui pourrait
sûr. Mais
c'est pour ça que ce matin, j'ai
fait en quelque sorte une frappe
préventive. Je l'ai dit que çaÇa
a absolument rien à voir avec
ça. À moins que je sois zéro
connecté sur moi-même et que den
inconscient, je peux vous dire
ça aucun rapport.
- Quand même, je vous pousse làs
était à 32, pouvait, avait une
chance de prendre le pouvoir.
- Ça ne changerait rien. Ça peu,
le pouvoir pour le pouvoir, j'y
crois pas. Je pense que je suis
un exemple qu'on peut réaliser
des choses dans l'opposition.
Moi les trois quart, si c'est
pas plus de ma vie politique
j'ai les ai vécu dans
l'opposition. J'ai été 18 mois
ministre. C'est tout. J'ai quand
même réalisé des réformes, donc
pas une fin en
soi. C'est ce à quoi on aspire
quand on va en politique
nt de pouvnt de pouvnt de pouvns
les leviers décisionnels, mais
je pense qu'il y a plein deu'one
autrement. Puis honnêtement,
je n'ai jamais cru dans lae base
personne. Je crois dans les
mouvements qui viennent de laban
parti de base avec beaucoup de
monde. Je pense qu'on estcapabls
manches sans évidemment avoir
nos lunettes roses et nous arc-
en-ciel devant nous. Je penseque
d'attaquer les choses et les
défis qui sont devant nous.
- On voyait aujourd'hui un
sondage, le Parti québécois est
à 9 %, c'est le plus bas depuis
que vous militez au Parti
québécois. Qu'est-ce qu'il se
passe d'abord et est-ce que vous
ne craignez pas que le parti ne
meurt?
- Non, je ne vois pas comment un
parti, le seul parti qui porte
la cause de l'indépendance,
pourrait disparaître. Je pense
que le Québec a besoin du Parti
québécois, je pense que nous on
a besoin au Parti québécois, de
reconnecté cette grande cause
là.
- Mais pourquoi ça ne marche
pas? Qu'est-ce qui est brisé?
- Je pense qu'il y a eu beaucoup
de désillusions, et je pense que
on avait besoin de rattacher ce
projet-là à la vie concrète des
gens. Qui vivent l'inflation,
qui n'ont pas de place en CP
Pour moi, ce projet-là résonne
dans toutes les sphères de notre
vie collective, mais
individuelle aussi. Je pense
il faut se pousser à faire ça.
Évidemment, il y a du travail de
reconstruction.
- Mme Hivon, avec
j'entends ça depuis 15 ans, 20
ans: Il faut reconnecter avec
les militants, il faut
réexpliquer. Manif
a quelque chose qui ne
fonctionne pas actuellement.
- Moi je pense qu'en fait, trop
longte
d'indépendance a été vu comme un
idéal désincarné du reste de la
vie. C'est quelque chose auconts
la vie des gens. Vous savez
quand on voit les sondages, voue
après sondage il y a encore 30 à
40 % des Québécois qui se disent
indépendantistes, mais ce n'est
pas leur priorité quand ils font
leur choix. Je pense que nous,
notre enjeu ce pourquoi il faut
se relever les manches, et
surprendre c'est de dire qu'à un
moment donné il va falloir se
faire assez confiance comme
Québécois pour se dire on est
capable de se dire oui.
La différence que ça ferait.
Évidemment il y a beaucoup de
travail. Les grandes causes,
nécessite du gros travail, des
grosses remises en question puis
je pense qu'avec la relève qu'on
a, on est capable de surprendre
la prochaine élection. En étant
très réaliste, très réaliste.
- C'est quoi surprendre, c'est
rester là?
(Rires)
- Puis je veux dire quand on est
des députés et un parti de c
d'idéale, ce n'est pas une fin
en soi le pouvoir. Donc d'avoir
des députés, d'en avoir plus
ux, mais çux, mais çux, mais çua
fait des gens qui se battent et
je pense qu'on a besoin d'avoir
ces gens-là avec nous. a eu dess
mots pour vous. Il a dit: j'ai
travaillé avec elle dans
Lanaudière, j'ai
Parti québécois avec elle etc.
Bravo et bonne continuation.
Est-ce que par ailleurs vous paa
prochaine campagne, lors de la
prochaine élection la CAQ, on le
voit avec les francophones elle
est omniprésente, prenne tout
l'espace politique? Est-ce qu'il
y a un côté malsain selon vousà?
- C'est certain. Je pense que
une saine démocratie, je veux
dire les gens n'ont jamais torti
décident, mais dans une saine
démocratie, le combat, le débat
autour des idées de
positionnement différents est
fondamental. C'est comme ça
qu'on est capable de faire
sortir le meilleur de nous-
mêmes. C'est en opposant, le
choc des idées. C'est sur que je
pense que la diversité des point
de vue et fondamental.
- Le plus beau, en terminant et
le plus laid en politique?
- Le plus beau c'est de réussir
à faire des changements qui
touchent la vie des gens dans le
plus concret, comme évidemment
le soin de fin de vie et l'aide
médicale à mourir et les
tribunaux spécialisés. Je pe
que c'est ça, quand tu as des
témoignages de gens qui ont dit
que ça changé la vie. Le plu
laid, je dirais c'est parfois ce
manque de civilité et cette
espèce de réflexe ultra pa
de penser que la personne en
face de nous est un ennemi alors
qu'elle est tout au plus un
adversaire politiq
devrait avoir de respect pour
tous ceux et celles qui font ce
choix là.
- Véroni
retrouver où? Vous savez ou vous
ne savez vraiment pas?
- Aucune idée, j'ai fait le saut
dans le vide en me lançant enise
saut dans le vide.
- Je vous laisse aller,
Véronique Hivon merci beaucoup,
député de Joliette, quelques
semaines encore, merci.- Merci,r